come back to CBS this morning I'm Gayle
King with Anthony Mason and Tony to
copal in an exclusive interview Harvey
Weinstein's new defense attorney tells
CBS this morning she is confident he
will be exonerated in the criminal cases
against him the former movie producers
you know is facing charges in New York
on allegations of sexual violence
against two women his trial starts in
January now more than 70 women have
accused him of wrongdoing since an
explosive New York Times investigation
two years ago that inspired the me to
movement Weinstein denies all of the
allegations his attorney Donna Burton Oh
is a former prosecutor and she's handled
dozens of cases defending men accused of
sexual misconduct between those comments
on me to may surprise you I've heard you
say that you're not really a believer or
supporter of the me2 movement it's more
of a supporter I think in many ways
there are good things about me too and
I've said this but what bothers me about
me too it it allows the court of public
opinion to take over the narrative and
when you can't come out and then either
correct or challenge that narrative it
puts you in a position where you're
stripped of your rights Chicago attorney
Donna row to know has built a reputation
defending men accused of sexual assault
and rape the trial of Harvey Weinstein
is her most high-profile case to date
what is your strategy in defending him
well I'm a strategy in defending him of
course is just evaluating the case for
for what it is in determining whether or
not these allegations are things that we
can refute and in the criminal case
there are two charged victims and in
both cases I feel strongly about the
fact that we have evidence that is
favorable to us and evidence that I
think will exonerate him we know we're
talking about two women but as you know
Donna the story is so much bigger than
that and I know you're not naive to that
because we've got really more than 70
women including names that we all know
Gweneth Paltrow Salma Hayek Ashley Judd
Lupita Nyong'o who have all said that
they were that Harvey Weinstein sexually
harassed them
I know you're saying these aren't
criminal cases but these are certainly
very serious allegations how do you
respond to that and does that matter to
you well sure I think it matters it
might matter to me and my analysis of
the whole sir and the whole circumstance
but if I look at the criminal case
frankly those those allegations don't
matter in the context of the criminal
case but how does Harvey explain those
allegations well I don't think it's
about explaining them anytime we talk
about men and women and sexual
circumstances I think we have to look at
the fact that there's always an area of
gray so there's these blurred lines and
I think sometimes one side walks away
from an event feeling different than the
other and how do we reconcile that it's
not uncommon for a woman who has been
through a very difficult traumatic
experience with a man to still be
engaged with that man and that's a
choice and if a woman makes that choice
she makes that choice but then I think
years later to come forward and then say
and who knows years later if your memory
is exactly the way something happened at
the time that you're claiming that it
did but I get frustrated when I listen
to these types of situations and I hear
women say well I didn't have a choice
well no you had a choice and you made a
choice we're focusing on your to
criminal cases but you do seem to
minimize all of the other charges and
allegations about Harvey Weinstein it's
not minimizing it but for my purposes in
this case it's not where I have to put
my time and attention it's really about
making sure those issues don't cloud our
ability to pick a to pick a fair jury in
addition of Harvey Weinstein's two
accusers at least three other women are
expected to testify so-called prior bad
act witnesses
their testimony will be used by
prosecutors to demonstrate a pattern of
behavior in the Bill Cosby case it was
involved in one woman but other women
who were charged who had made
allegations were allowed to testify and
that seemed to have made a decision in
the verdict for the jury certainly in
the second case are you concerned about
that sure I think there's always a
concern about those things I think the
notion of where there's smoke there's
fire as is always something that we have
to worry about is more than fire though
this is an inferno when it comes to her
well I think I think that when you look
at the criminal case I don't think that
that's the case I'm not here to say that
he was not guilty of committing sins I'm
not here to say that at all but there's
a difference between sins and crimes and
I don't think he's a rapist
I don't think no I do believe he's a
rapist do you ever worry that you're
making it harder for women who have been
sexually harassed assaulted raped to
come forward no I would hope that I'm
making it easier for them I was doing
what I'm doing makes them realize they
have choices and if they really are in a
position that they feel uncomfortable
then the first thing they should do is
report it they should go to the police
and I think that that's sort of weeding
out the cases that don't rise to the
level of real assaults should help real
victims so no I think I'm helping them
actually doesn't a man have to take
responsibility for his now question no
choices that he made no question and I
think that no matter what happens to
Harvey Weinstein he will pay the biggest
price there is but even if he wins Gail
his whole life has been ruined toppled
damaged and whether it's it's by his own
doing or others that's the fact and the
fact is that no matter what we do and we
can walk out of that courtroom with a
not guilty and walk him out under those
courtroom steps and he never gets to be
Harvey Weinstein ever again now Harvey
Weinstein denies the accusations and
faces a sentence of up to life in prison
if convicted
donna retino says Harvey Weinstein has
been very involved in the preparation of
his case and they've not yet decided
whether he's going to take the stand the
Gloria Allred who represents accuser
Mimi Haleh is imploring him to do so in
a statement to CBS this morning she
writes this I
Challenge Harvey Weinstein to take the
witness stand and deny under oath the
testimony of prosecution witnesses
against him
it's extraordinary conversation mystery
to know wants to focus on the crimes not
what she says are the sin exactly on the
subject of the crimes did she tell you
anything about what kind of jury the
Weinstein team is looking for well I
asked her you know do you have a jury in
mind she said of course I do but I'm not
telling you because I don't want to tip
my hand but she has she has a very
specific strategy in mind she's very
confident you know articles written
about her described there was a bulldog
in the courtroom I asked her is that an
accurate or fair assessment she said I
didn't say that one of my clients did
but she's definitely taking it as a
compliment she's very confident and very
sure about what she's doing this
particular will be very interesting to
see what the makeup of that jury turns
out to be exactly